alors c'est vrai qu'il y ait refait
encore parler des danseurs ça vous
croyez que j'ai vu à la vente mais tout
est fait vraiment personnellement j'ai
participé il ya 3-4 dans ma mère si ça
voilà sincèrement on a été vraiment
maltraité pendant vraiment on a été dans
des conditions minables on a été jeté
sur scène on n'a même pas été diffusés
finalement parce qu'ils ont un petit
scandale et punir l'histoire un côté
nous en fait l'histoire c'est que ma
mère ça fait trente ans qu'elle chante
et on est passé du coup à l'antenne 11
ans nous a jetés sur scène on a attendu
de 8 heures du matin jusqu'à 20h on est
passé super tard et tout on a attendu
vraiment on n'a pas une mouche ne me dit
rien du tout il faisait super froid on
était tous entassés dans une seule donc
ma mère a fait du chant pendant trente
ans sur scène du bal auch vraiment pur
et puis elle est passée sur scène avec
moi gilbert rozon osé dire que ma mère
n'était pas chanteuse professionnelle
selon lui et qu'elle devrait plutôt se
faire virer de l'émission mais me garder
seulement moi il a dit ça devant
toujours ma mère m'a invité comme pays
depuis depuis vous habitez toujours j'ai
aux parents mais du coup on a trouvé ça
inadmissible et puis même tout écrit les
j'adore savoir les coulisses comme ça
voyez satiné comme à la même question
alors regarder dans d'autres médias et
au moins on a quelqu'un qui va regarder
de l'intérieur mais on l'a fait trois
ans mieux moi c'est un truc de fou
il appelle mauvais débat ça fait 25 ans
de la durée